who wants the hands up and give us um
their suggestion for their definition of
a credit card any takers any takers
yeah piece of plastic
i like that is a piece of plastic i
spelled that right
yes yeah okay
with what was the end of your
with money you don't have okay
money you
don't
have i quite like that anyone want to
advance on that
my definition that i had in my head was
very similar actually um i left out the
plastic bit a credit card is a way to
spend money that isn't yours that's the
basic idea okay
which is what we have here money that
you don't have
it's not just money you don't have it's
money that someone else your creditor
is willing
to put forward for you
let's make this a bit concrete okay
creditors creditors are usually banks or
other big organizations which are
basically like banks okay so i thought
i'd put a bit you know make a little
concrete for you um and i had a
bit bored so suppose you go to a bank
all right
and um
you go up and you say look look i
i need to i would like to um spend spend
more money than i actually have in my
hands right now okay you know maybe you
want to do it for you know really
legitimate purposes maybe you want to
start a business something like that
okay we've talked about examples like
this before
so you come to the bank right and you
will need to prove what would you want
to prove to the bank in order for the
bank to hand back to you
a credit card
yep
fantastic so you want to be able to
prove i'm good for the money you're
going to lend me okay i'm good for the
credit that you're going to put to my
name all right so that might be how
would you prove that
credit history number one
credit history
okay i heard another one was it
assets very good which means that if it
turns out that you're not good for your
um for your credit i can go and sell off
the stuff that you have and make that
back
um there's one other following helpful
information which is your income
so in practice that's going to be pay
slips right we want that to be
consistent we want to be permanent all
those kinds of things okay
so
you bring all of this to the table and i
say sure okay i will hand you this fancy
piece of plastic which i'm not going to
face you for too long because then
you'll see the number okay so there you
go right what happens with this thing
what can you do with it
you can buy things so let's do a flow
chart here okay so here we go here's you
right because you
hey it's pretty accurate drawing all
right now you go ahead to the shops okay
are you going to buy some stuff right
but because all you've got is this piece
of plastic right no money actually goes
for the goods from you to the shop where
does it come from
it comes from me right so my my big you
know um hold on how does it look like i
didn't know
there you go this is my big
cloud of money in the air and i pay the
shops okay and i pay where else are you
gonna go where else you gonna spend some
money
really that's that's that's it really
you can't spend you can't spend your
money on anything else okay you spend
some okay oh now this is interesting um
you know
a car a car with something very hard to
buy on a credit card can someone tell me
why
there is depreciation to worry about but
that's not mainly my concern how much
does a car cost what kind of price range
are you going to be aiming for
yeah 10 000 plus for like this decent
secondary car 20 000 plus if you want a
really nice brand new car so therefore
that kind of amount of money
you know even if you do have all this
kind of stuff i'm not willing to just
hand to you okay i want a contract or
that kind of thing i'm not just going to
give it to you through a piece of
plastic right
general kind of credit limit
up here
a credit limit
which is
how much am i willing to lend you is
kind of well they're generally under ten
thousand dollars okay so
no wrong way
under ten thousand dollars in fact you
might start off with say two two
thousand dollars and then as you
demonstrate that you have a good credit
history that you're paying things back
on time they'll say they'll invite you
i'll invite you would you like to
increase your credit limit right because
it's better for me if you spend more
money because then i can well
i can charge more interest okay so let's
start to get to that
i didn't go to i wouldn't go westpac for
this next piece of information i went to
oh spoilers let's go here i wonder if
you saw that
here is here is commonwealth banks one
of their bank accounts okay um was the
most recent one i could find and you can
see there's an interest rate here it's
pretty small
um in in more than one way 2.5 percent
is their standard rate and there's some
kind of promotion at the moment which
gives you 3.7
okay so if you want to think about this
way this is the commonwealth bank doing
this
but in reverse right so it's like you're
putting money in the bank your savings
right so you're lending money to the
bank
so they're paying you for that
does that make sense you with me so far
okay good
so this is kind of like a going rate
right if i lend you money i would charge
this amount if you lend me money you
might charge that amount and we're kind
of equal partners here okay and this
rate goes up and down those of you
studying economics you know the forces
that make it fluctuate
all right now
i wonder if you can guess some of you
might know this number okay this is for
how much money you're going to earn in a
bank account right well the credit card
is exactly the same idea isn't it it's
them lending you money on a short term
basis month to month right
so what do you think would be a
reasonable interest rate for them to
charge you
for the privilege of borrowing their
money
they're giving you 2.5
how much are you expecting that they'll
want you to give them any suggestions
well
let's have a look
cba has um a few credit cards so i'll
show you their what they call their low
rate credit card
here it is okay i wonder if you can
decipher this it is a bit small
where's the important figure okay
there's a couple of fees that you have
to pay no matter how much or how little
you spend and your fees eligible
customers so if you've got like really
good stuff like this or you have
something else packaged with cba like a
home loan or something like that
but what's the crucial number can you
see it
right in there
13. that's very good
0.49
13.49
percent thirteen point four nine percent
that is my calculator is telling me more
than five times the amount that they'll
pay you
to give them money they're like you give
us money we'll pay you 2.5
but you take money from me
and you don't pay back on time i'll
charge you this okay now there's this
other number down here much higher that
reads 21.24 can anyone make out what is
that
cash advance interest rate and there's a
big difference between these okay
purchase cash advance
purchase is this scenario okay you make
a purchase
and that's how much they'll charge you
you can kind of tell by the name what do
you think this is it's a different
process
right right very good so it's you going
to an atm
right you go to the atm and if you want
actual hold in your hands money they're
going to charge you higher just bit of a
thought experiment for you
i wonder why you think that is the case
why do you think it is that this
is so much higher than this when
kind in essence
it's the same thing isn't it you're
borrowing money from the same guys
i'll let you have a think about it okay
at the end of the lesson i'll tell you
an answer if you're still really curious
now by the way i told you this was the
this is the low rate right so they have
another card which is called their low
fee credit card in case you don't want
to pay so much on a regular basis
but as a trade-off you're going to get a
higher interest rate so let me show you
their inverted commerce low fee credit
card ah there it is
cash advance is the same
interesting
but their purchase interest rate is
almost 20 so these are quite close
together
what's lower is this fee in here what do
you think is worth it